hola pues en este vídeo quiero seguir
haciendo ejemplos de funciones
trigonométricas así que como antes voy a
dibujar mi triángulo rectángulo
y les recuerdo la definición que dado de
funciones trigonométricas hasta ahora
sólo funciona con triángulos rectángulos
así que no la vayan a tratar de utilizar
para calcular otras cosas pero bueno
vamos a suponer que este lado de aquí
vale 4 y voy a imaginar que este lado de
acá vale 7 ya sé que parece que miden lo
mismo pero tendremos que usar nuestra
imaginación así que cuánto vale la
hipotenusa que les recuerdo es el lado
que está opuesto al ángulo recto así que
estoy aquí es la hipotenusa y pues
nosotros sabemos del teorema de
pitágoras de nuestras clases de
geometría o de vídeos pasados que la
hipotenusa al cuadrado la longitud de la
hipotenusa al cuadrado es igual a la
suma de los cuadrados de las longitudes
de los otros dos lados que les recuerdo
se llaman catetos así que bien esto
sería igual
7 al cuadrado 7 al cuadrado más
4 al cuadrado
de modo que
h al cuadrado sería igual a 7 al
cuadrado es 49 más 4 al cuadrado
16 49 y 16 es 65 de modo que al cuadrado
es igual a 65 y si saco raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados
no tengo que h es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 65 noten que ya no puede
reducir más este número puesto que 65 es
13 por 5 y ese número es libre cuadrados
así que h va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 65
muy bien ahora qué pasa si me pregunto
por las funciones trigonométricas de
este ángulo de aquí vamos a llamar este
ángulo theta entonces pues lo primero
que voy a hacer es escribir mi
mnemotecnia de show
acá
es esta demo técnica es súper súper útil
para poder calcular las funciones
trigonométricas de triángulos
rectángulos es decir de ángulos que
puedo meter en triángulos rectángulos de
modo que bien por ejemplo qué pasa si me
preguntó por el coseno y coseno del
ángulo teta
pues entonces tengo que irme a la parte
correspondiente de shock a toa en
particular tengo que irme acá porque acá
me dice que el coseno
el coche no es igual a ade adyacente / h
de hipotenusa
así que cose no es igual adyacente /
hipotenusa y recuerden que significará
eso la hipotenusa es esto de aquí
esto no cambia adyacente es el lado
adyacente o el cateto adyacente al
ángulo que simplemente es el otro lado
del triángulo que digamos forma el borde
del ángulo en este caso sería este lado
de aquí que vale 4 este sería el lado
adyacente
adyacente recuerden si cambio el ángulo
si ahora me fijaré en este ángulo el
lado adyacente sería ahora 7 pero como
estoy concentrado en theta este lado que
vale 4 es el adyacente así que el coste
no de teta vale la magnitud del lado
adyacente que es 4 dividido entre la
magnitud de la hipotenusa que es raíz de
país de 65 ahora bien a muchas personas
no les gusta tener números irracionales
en el denominador por lo que podría
racionalizar esta fracción simplemente
multiplicando por raíz de 65
/ raíz de 65 noten que este número entre
este número como son iguales es
simplemente 1 por lo tanto estoy
multiplicando por 1 y este número no va
a cambiar para nada pero cuánto es eso
pues eso me daría 4 x raíz de 65 4 x
raíz de 65 /
/ raíz de 75 x raíz de 65 es simplemente
65 así que ese sería el valor del coste
no detecta que hay de el seno de teta
el seno de eta cuanto a patri eso pues
ahora la que me sirve eso eso me dice
que el seno es igual a o de opuesto
/ h de hipotenusa así que el seno es el
lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa y cuál
es el lado opuesto al ángulo theta pues
basta ver aquí el ángulo theta abre
hacia este lado
así este lado que vale 7 que mide 7
unidades déjenme lo escribo este sería
el opuesto el lado opuesto o cateto
opuesto
así que seno de teta es igual a la
magnitud del cateto puesto que es 7
dividido entre la hipotenusa la magnitud
de la hipotenusa que es raíz de 65 de
nuevo puede racionalizar esta expresión
multiplicando por raíz de 65 entre raíz
de 65
y eso me daría
7 por la raíz cuadrada de 65
dividido entre 65
muy bien que hay finalmente de la
tangente en gente de eta pues ahora
todas me dice que tangente es igual a
odio puesto entre adyacente
pero cuál es el lado opuesto a el ángulo
theta es este que tiene longitud 7
así que tangente teta sería 7 /
el lado adyacente que es este que tiene
longitud 4
así que la tangente de teta vale 7 entre
hagamos otro ejemplo bien me bajó un
poco para tener más espacio y voy a
dibujar aquí mi triángulo
está la hipotenusa un cateto y el otro
cateto
soy muy malo dibujando triángulos
ustedes disculpen pero bueno vamos a
suponer que la hipotenusa vale 4 que la
longitud de este cateto es 2 y que la
longitud de este otro cateto de este
otro lado es 2 x raíz de 3 y de hecho
podemos verificar que esto funciona
porque debe obedecer el teorema de
pitágoras y cuánto es 2 por raíz de 3 al
cuadrado más 2 al cuadrado pues esto
sería lo mismo que 4 x 3 + 2 al cuadrado
que sería 4 4 por 13 12 + 4 es 16
y 16 en efecto es 4 al cuadrado que es
la longitud de la hipotenusa al cuadrado
y bueno quizás reconozcan este triángulo
de los cursos de geometría o de algún
otro vídeo como un triángulo 30-60 es
decir este ángulo de aquí es de 30
grados y este ángulo de acá
es de 60 grados la razón por la que se
eso es porque este cateto es la mitad de
la hipotenusa mide la mitad que la
hipotenusa y porque este otro cateto es
raíz de 3 por la longitud de este otro
cateto así que bueno espero que
reconozcan este triángulo no quiero
hacer ahorita un repaso de todas las
propiedades que tiene pero lo que sí
quiero hacer es calcular sus funciones
trigonométricas y recuerden déjenme lo
vuelve escribir acá y acá
recuerden este triángulo rectángulo así
que nos puede servir esto
yang y comencemos cuánto vale el por
ejemplo el cose no el coseno de 30
grados
pues el coseno de 30 grados que me dice
que es co se no es igual adyacente entre
hipotenusa cuál es el lado adyacente al
ángulo de 30 grados pues fíjense que es
este lado de aquí es precisamente este
lado el que forma el borde del ángulo
junto con la hipotenusa así que el
coseno de 30 grados valdría 2 x raíz de
3 entre 4 o si simplificó esto
simplemente sería raíz de 3
entre dos bien que pasa ahora si me
pregunto por digamos el seno el seno de
30 grados
ahora que me dices toca todas pues la
que me importa eso y me dice que el seno
es igual al cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa cuál es el cateto opuesto al
ángulo de 30 grados pues el ángulo de 30
grados abre hacia este 2 de aquí hacia
de este lado que vale 2 así que este
sería mi lado opuesto
el seno valdría a 2 entre la longitud de
la hipotenusa que es 4 por lo que el
seno de 30 grados es igual a un medio y
recuerden esto es una función del ángulo
así que mientras el triángulo contenga
ese ángulo y sea rectángulo claro puedo
utilizar estas definiciones aunque el
triángulo sea más chico por lo tanto si
en algún momento se topan con el seno o
el coseno de 30 o 60 grados pueden
utilizar este triángulo porque satisface
todas las condiciones
pero bueno no nos distraigamos cuánto
vale la tangente ahora la tangente de 30
grados toca todas todas me dice que la
tangente es igual a el cateto puesto
entre el cateto adyacente cuál es el
cateto opuesto acabamos de ver que es 2
o más bien mide 2 entre la longitud del
cateto adyacente que es este de aquí y
vale 2 x raíz de 32 por raíz de 3 de
nuevo podría si quisiera racionalizar
este denominador bueno esto para empezar
es uno entre raíz de 3 puedo multiplicar
por raíz de 3 / raíz de 3 para
racionalizar
y esto me da raíz de 3 entre 3 y bueno
ya que tenemos este triángulo aquí vamos
a aprovechar para calcular las funciones
trigonométricas del ángulo de 60 grados
comencemos de nuevo con el coche no
coseno de 60 grados espero que ustedes
ya lo puedan calcular muy rápido cuánto
vale el coseno de 60 grados pues ahora
el cateto adyacente al ángulo de 60
grados es ahora este cateto de aquí
este cateto de aquí que vale o tiene
longitud 2 así que el coche no es 60
grados sería 2 entre la hipotenusa que
es coseno igual adyacente entre
hipotenusa la hipotenusa vale 4 así que
esto va a valer 1 entre 2
bien continuemos cuánto valdrá el seno
de 60 grados pues el seno de 60 grados
es por sol es el cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa ahora para el ángulo de 60
grados este ángulo abre hacia este lado
de modo que el cateto opuesto al ángulo
de 60 grados es este que mide 2 x raíz
de 3
y ya 2 por raíz de 3 entre la longitud
de la hipotenusa que de nuevo es 4
por lo que el seno de 60 grados es igual
a raíz de 3 entre 2
y finalmente cuánto vale la tangente la
tangente de 60 grados pues ahora tengo
tangente igual a opuesto entre adyacente
lo que sería la longitud del cateto
opuesto es 2 por raíz de 3 entre la
longitud del cateto adyacente que es 22
12 se cancelan y simplemente me queda
raíz de 3 ahora bien no teme que el
coseno de 30 grados fue igual al seno de
60 grados y que el coseno de 60 grados
es igual al seno de 30 grados y que la
tangente de 30 grados es igual a 1 entre
la tangente de 60 grados así que bueno
posteriormente exploraremos estas
relaciones y extenderemos las funciones
trigonométricas o más bien la definición
de las funciones trigonométricas para
calcular ángulos que no estén entre 0 y
90 grados